bonsoir merad et brahimi oui vous soir
alors en quoi la révélation des messages
entre des employés faisant état de
dysfonctionnements de l'appareil
en quoi c'est crucial dans toute cette
histoire ce qui est important en fait ce
n'est pas une conversation entre deux
employés c'est entre deux pilotes et ça
c'est très important de mentionner
pourquoi parce que les pilotes d'essai
où les pilotes de test dans les
compagnies sont un petit peu des
sentinelles ceux qui sont si vous voulez
à la fin de la chaîne vos d'une certaine
manière testait ce que les ingénieurs
mettent au point
autrement dit les ingénieurs conçoivent
des systèmes elle donc ils les tests et
après lé là je dirais le test ultime
c'est quand tout ça cet ensemble et donc
les pilotes que ce soit dans le
simulateur
où que ce soit en vols dans le vrai coq
mais ils vont tester ça et là on est en
présence de deux pilotes tong qui voit
qu'il ya un problème dont il ya un
pilote qui dit à l'autre écoute j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté dans le
simulateur avec les crs et j'ai menti
donc a donc aux régulateurs par rapport
à cette question-là lots tribales ne
t'inquiète pas tu as pas manquer parce
que ils t'ont pas posé la question et ça
c'est quelque chose de très important
parce que les pilotes jouent un rôle
crucial dans mon engagement moral qui
est très important dans la culture de
sécurité dans l'aviation aussi un
engagement technique juridique et légale
de rapporter ce qui ne fonctionne pas et
là on est en train de voir cet élément
là et ça ça révèle une sorte de culture
dans cette entreprise qui s'est
installée ou la culture de dos
d'hypocrites mensonges de falsification
pour bien sûr tenter des tirs et des
objectifs financiers ou d'aider les
atteintes que ça c'est très très grave
vous parlez d'une culture est-ce que
c'est étendu ses boeing c'est un cas qui
est vraiment à part
alors écoutez ça fait plusieurs années
dans le milieu de management et tout ça
dans les écoles de gestion même on
utilise de plus en plus le gars boeing
comme une espèce de retournement de la
situation pour lui pendant des décennies
a été très fier et à juste titre de
cette culture de sécurité qui ré
et à tous les niveaux de la de
l'entreprise que ça soit au niveau de la
conception que ce soit au niveau des
tests que ce soit au niveau du service
après vente
donc c'était ça mais depuis
l'acquisition de mcdonald's
yann et l'arrivée d'une nouvelle
catégorie de gestionnaires la culture
d'ingénieurs a laissé sa place à la
culture de financiers et ça ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui a déjà dans les années 2000
il ya des grandes d'ingénieurs très
connue et reconnue au sein de bouygues
donc à certains sponsors schnell
cherchell qui a mentionné cet élément
disant écoutez on est on est en train de
donner la gouvernance de l'entreprise à
des financiers qui considèrent
aujourd'hui fabrique un avion comme si
par exemple montrent un logiciel ou un
prêt hypothécaire ou n'importe quel
produit agroalimentaire donc on est on
est en train de s'éloigner de cette
culture donc de cette obsession dans le
sens positif du terme pour la sécurité
en train de partir et donc les
financiers ont pris ont pris le contrôle
et c'est quand même c'est quand même
grave si on arrive à sacrifier en
quelque sorte la sécurité je présume que
le 30 octobre devant le congrès quand on
va poser des questions à boeing
c'est cesser de cela qu'on va parler de
la sécurité de la culture d'entreprise
est ce qu'on peut me questionner
l'avenir de boeing tout à fait alors
bombe brune dans les dernières semaines
des derniers mois on sait de faire une
espèce de l'opération de charme
alors ils ont repensé la structure
entreprises y sont ajoutées dont une
unité de la sécurité donc de l'habiller
de la navigabilité et donc de la
production ce qui est étrange comment ça
se fait que l'on met aujourd'hui un
style unités alors que sa tête le souci
principal
on a vu une dame qui a une certaine
notoriété est très reconnu nos pasteurs
donc dans la direction mais mais c'est
un petit peu tout ça c'est un peu trop
tard la confiance est brisé comme on va
comment cette espèce de si vous voulez
collusion entre l' agence régulatrice
téva et donc la compagnie on voit
comment il ya vraiment des il ya des
desana liste notamment
sochaux qui dit ça ça n'a pas de sens
c'est comme un espèce de stagiaire de 23
ans qui était à la commande de boeing te
faire autant de bêtises et sortent ce
qui est grave c'est que bon une cité par
pti pas mal de son savoir faire et de la
même si aujourd'hui voulait revenir vers
ce que de culture de sécurité ils ont
été tellement dans un logique financière
de haute saône 2 2 en dessous s'est
excusé moi le terme et est donc ils ont
une bonne partie de la conception de
logiciels sas a été fait par des jeunes
diplômés des universités indiennes qui
ont été payées 9 $ l'heure
ça n'était plus part des ingénieurs donc
de boulin qui avaient une connaissance
dans le domaine alentours
le 30 octobre on va avoir des choses à
ce niveau là il voit tout mais je pense
que on n'aura pas des révélations
extraordinaires mais d'autres
l'assemblée il ya déjà commencé à
choisir son bouquet musique et son
président et pdg qui a repéré anti
bieber va démissionner vous croyez je ne
sais pas s'il va démissionner notre cas
c'est sûr que jusqu'à maintenant dit bon
bah écoutez il ya on a je pense que dans
l'état actuel ce serait très grave de
tout l'été mettre tous ses fonctions
pour l'instant on a pu trouver voir un
petit peu je dirais pour ne pas perdre
la face en disant bon il n'est plus
président on va le libérer pour qu'il
occupe tout son temps à la gérer paul de
lay la crise de 737 mais je pense que ça
prend plus que ça aujourd'hui pour gérer
la crise de 737 et on va revoir cet
avion dans les airs un jour vous croyez
en terminale
on va certainement revoir parce que les
enjeux sont importants nous pas dire
c'est qu'il commande et le prix d'avion
620 millions $ ça représente 600
milliards de dollars ans et c'est énorme
donc on va le revoir mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit un avion qui a un avenir
brillant déjà il ya beaucoup de pilotes
qui ont porté plainte qui ne veulent pas
là de le voir dans le ciel et je pense
que d'ici là tony essaiera probablement
de mettre au point un avion de
remplacement et de convertir certain
nombre de commandes 700 tracé dans cette
nouvelle avions là mais il est évident
que cet avion à un problème de
conception de base de ce logiciel ne
peut pas régler ce problème de
conception
on ne peut pas tricher avec les lois de
la nature ce que le boeing a voulu faire
et vous voyez un petit peu le résultat
mehran ebrahimi en californie ce soir
merci
beaucoup c'est toujours un plaisir cette
union et à très bientôt